その経営者がどういう考え方の人間かって
ことなんですよだこれが器なんだよこの器
作りに研修やり続けんだよ俺青木哲の人生
経営哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですねあの中小企業中層企業は
経営者で決まるってよくおっしゃられると
思うんですけれどもこれってぶっちゃけ
どういう意味なんですかていうことについ
てお聞せいたうんと思いますなるほど
[音楽]
結局ね経営者っていうのはま人も金を
マネージメントし
ながらま1つの価値を作り出し続けていく
というまそういう立場にある人間なんです
よねで結局経営者自身の器物の見方考え方
それがまず利己的か理的か
から心ざしがあるか心志しってのは社会の
ためとか系の目的がねもしくは全くそう
いう志しなんかないまいろんな人がいると
思うんですよま
結局その経営者の考え方以上でも以下でも
ない特に私は中小企業の傾斜教育を長年に
渡ってやってきましたま実際7000人を
超える経営者にですねこの3日間の研修を
提供してきたわけですよねま最近はもう
特に経営者だけを対象にま今も上場企業の
ね経営者とかもたくさん中堅企業の経営者
もたくさん入ってくるのでま1回大体
300人400人の経営者を対象に私は
メッセージをしい続けてきました結局ね
その経営者がどういう考え方の人間かって
ことなんですよ対顧客対社員とその家族
ですよねそれから対おき先対
株主対社会に対してどういう考え方を持っ
てるのかなんですようんある経営者であの
社員のことをパーツって呼んだ人間がいた
からね最悪
でしょでもその経営者の悩みがいい人材が
取れなくて離職が多いってこと当たり前
だってだ元になる考え方がパーツだから
そうでしょう私はリーマンショックが
あろうと
東日本大震災があろうとまあそして今回の
コロナ何があろうと1ともリストラなんて
考えたことが
ないうんだからうちの会社ってのはもし仮
にねなんだろうそのうまくいかなくなった
時どうするかって言うとリストラじゃなく
てまずみんなで話し合って全体の報酬
下げると思うんだよでもその前にまず経営
者の報酬を下げるよな順番としては次経営
責任を持ってる慶人の報酬下げるよねで
役職者の報酬まもっと言うと決算所用の額
が下がってきてまもちろん派遣だとか
パートの人はちょっと場合によっては人数
減らすかもしれないよねでも社員を切ると
いう発想は味人もないでもこれ僕の考え方
でしょどこにもなんかそういう教科書が
あったわけじゃないんだよねこうしろと
言われてるわけじゃないじゃん経営者って
全部自分の意思決定で全てが未来が決まる
わけじゃんねでもうち新卒から入ってくれ
てまそれこそ今役員になったね高橋に橋本
にしろ17年18年勤めてるわけじゃない
ですかま彼らはどこの会社行っても活躍し
ますよだけど新卒から長年勤めてくれてる
人間に対して会社がうまくいかないから
よその会社行けとは言えないよねこれ
プライドかけてあのねそうそうこれもね
考え方なんだけどある人がね採用ってね
そんな青木さんね力む必要ないよって恋愛
じゃないいて恋愛で考えたらいいじゃない
てだから恋愛はよく見せるじゃないですか
で引っかけるとね口説き落とすとで目標
達成したらさよならとまた次行けばいい
じゃないですかてこいつダメな野郎だなと
思ったの俺なんとふきな不誠実な野郎だと
とんでもないと思ったわけ僕は結婚って
考えちゃうタイプなんですよだってさ
いろんな会社る中で新卒でだよこの会社で
やろうって決めてくれたわけじゃんいやだ
からここがポイントなのよこの感謝を持っ
てるよね俺はでも多くの経営者使ってやっ
てるとかさ分かる逆なのよ生活見てやっ
てるとかバカじゃねえかとお前んとこにい
なくたっていくらでも会社なんてあるよと
もっと感謝の頃だこれが器なんだよこの器
作りに研修やり続けんだよ俺
だからねこう再のある人間が陥るのは
人使いが下手なんですで人が使えない人間
は経は下手です人が
いかに内発的にやる気になり本当に一緒に
このチームで最高の価値を作り出せるか
どうかそれが面白さなんですよお金じゃ
ないんですよなも合なんか出さなくただっ
てみんな働きもなりますでも多くのね人は
例えば社員の能力を開発してったら離職さ
れるんじゃないかそれは魅力がないから
でしょって僕は全くそういう不安ないです
それはしょうがないよ自分に魅力がなけれ
ば去られてもしょうがない
よねそれでもすがってさ頼むからやないで
くれみたいな俺プライドかけたそんなこと
言えないよそうでしょだから僕ができる
ことって何かって言うと社員の側に立って
社員から見て理想の会社とはどういう会社
なんだろうとそういう会社を考えて一生
懸命それを実現できるように最善の努力を
するしかないんですよ今なんでこの話をし
てるかとこれは僕の考え方じゃないです
か分かりますよねだから経営者の器でその
会社の未来は決まっちゃうんですよって
いうのはその経営者の考え方に共感した
人間が入ってくるでチームができたり
それぞれの役割を果たしてくわけじゃんで
結局利己的な考え方持ってたら当然くり反
になるし優秀な人間から抜けてっちゃうよ
ねそしたら大きな仕事って絶対できない
じゃないですかうちはこれからですから
うん37やってきてこれからってい表現変
なんだけどもっと大きなことできると思い
ますよもっと言うともっと大きな貢献が
できると思いますいや本当にだから僕この
YouTube見てもらってるね学生諸君
には是非アチーブメントね採用してあの門
称えてもらいたいと思うもし人材教育人材
育成という分野に興味があるならばでも
シンガポールにしても人に対する投資杯
じゃないですよ今アジア見てもその国家の
1番の財産何かって言ったら人だって言っ
てますよだから人に対して投資しないよう
な国は未来がないじゃないですかだから
企業も同じなんですだ経営者の考え方で
その会社は決まる間違いないうんだから中
小企業だけではないですうん私はもうあの
大気温のね経営者とも当初の議員企業です
から接してるし経団連にも入ってるし経済
同権にも入っていろんな人と接するけどで
もねやっぱり基本的には得と再のある人間
が上に上がっていってる特に大企業はそう
だねはいだ馬鹿にしちゃだめですよ大企業
の経営者はやっぱり人格的にも素晴らしい
人いっぱいいますうんあの公務員でもね
やっぱり霞ヶ関の人たちと付き合うと
やっぱ人間的に素晴らしいですよまメシ
暴行って言葉あるけど自分をゼロにしてで
も国のために命を捧げるそれぐらいの差し
持ってる人いっぱいいます
よ民間の方がフミある意味ではね特にあの
なんだろうグロスに上場してねまもう上場
して上場液得ることだけをさ目標にして
上がったらもうそれでなんか伸び悩んでる
会社って戦略がないのよそれと自分のもう
創業者理事得ることばっかり考えてんだ
もんそり社員はね手足でしょそういう会社
には明はないうんだからまある意味では
経営者自身がしっかりと襟を正して
向き合っていかなきゃいけないと思います
よ経営にまそんな風に思いますありがとう
ございますこれねあの3日ぐらいかかるん
だよこの話するのはうんもうこの辺にやめ
ときますはいもう暑くなってくるとこっ
から始まるから3日間はいありがとう
ございますはい
これはねうん人を相手にしてる仕事なん
ですよお客様であろうと社員であろうと
社員の家族お取引き先であろうと株主で
あろうとともかく人を対象にしていますだ
から人に対しては真心誠実さを持ってこと
に
あたるそして規模を負うことなく質を負う
そして今一緒に働いてくれてる人の生活
水準をどうしたら高めてあげられるのか
それは本人の考え方や知識や技術を総合的
に高めていかなければいけないでももう
すでに昔からいる人のその伸び代はそれ
ほど期待できないと思うかもしれないなら
ば新しい若い人をやっぱり積極的に採用し
ながらもしくは事業で言うと新規事業を
作ってその今までの人たちもちゃんと生活
を守ってあげられるような経営を考えて
いくそれがやっぱり経営者の責任じゃない
かと思いますま是非商人してください経営
者の能力開発がその会社の未来を決定し
ます是非頑張っていただきたいと思います
え是非ねえコメント欄に今の私の
メッセージを聞いて感じたこと受け止めた
こと書き込んでくださいあとチャンネル
登録まだの方は是非チャンネル登録忘れ
ないでくださいよろしくお願いします